eu tenho uma má notícia pra vocês
a medicina está doente mas tem uma boa
notícia também a gente pode curar a arte
de curar a arte de curar ser médico
ela é apoiada uma pedra fundamental na
relação médico-paciente aonde eu tenho
que me envolver e espiritualmente de tal
maneira que compreende o sofrimento
daquele indivíduo que eu tenha compaixão
que eu tenho aí tem batia mas ao mesmo
tempo eu tenho que ter um distanciamento
tal que me permita ter um rigor técnico
é um julgamento técnico e para que eu
possa opor o melhor tratamento daquele
indivíduo
esse equilíbrio está muito delicada e as
relações humanas no nosso tempo com
todas as mais prejudiciais mais rasas
o equilíbrio está sofrendo nos últimos
dez anos na amazônia mais de 25 vezes
com cirurgia
nessas viagens eu acompanhei muitos
médicos que também foram lá quando a
gente chegou lá na nossa arrogância de
alguma coisa mas investiu índia
lá eu reencontrei no sentimento em um
dia desde a infância me relacionar com
alguém que precisava do que eu sabia
fazer e de poder oferecer aquela pessoa
aquele ter envolvimento daquele amor
esse atendimento
lá ele está colado nos convênios pedido
de exame de horários honorário
todos os médicos que vão a gente volta
de lá que a simplificação que ocorre lá
pode ser replicado aqui também é preciso
e primeiro da amazônia
o bicho foi o caminho que eu encontrei
para descobrir em um estudo que mostra
que no começo da faculdade de medicina
se você fizer uma lista de tópicos de
objetivos dos alunos
os primeiros objetivos tão altruísmo
fazer o bem
esses mesmos alunos no fim do curso de
medicina com a mesma pesquisa os tópicos
acima são sucesso reconhecimento cura
alguma coisa a gente fez de errado a
gente pegou em que tinha esteve
brilhante poética ea gente entregou em
técnico que sabe muito a medicina não
sabe nada de gente
a preocupação com relação médico
paciente
na grécia o berço da medicina onde está
o pai da medicina hipócrates não quer
dizer que vai ficar apertado quando adam
engasgou com a maçã com ele isso foi
fazer uma diária pedras é o que a gente
faz negócio com a mesma coisa porque que
a creche é considerado mesmo define
pouco tempo para medicina porque pela
primeira vez ele é um método pode somou
a fim de curar uma coisa que faça
ensinada aprendida reproduzida replicado
e da maneira que o que é é o
envolvimento dessas pessoas que tinham
uma lógica
naquela ocasião também foi desenvolvido
foi criado no momento de portas que até
hoje é usado nas formaturas de medicina
num foi feito nesta quinta antes de
cristo a palavra muito complexo você
paga em três palavras em todas as casas
que entrar
falei apenas para benefício dos doentes
evitando tomar um voluntário ea
corrupção especialmente a redução das
mulheres dos nomes das crianças do
cérebro
por aquilo que vi ouvi respeitante a
vida dos doentes no exercício da minha
profissão ou fora dela e que não convém
aqui seja divulgado
guardar e silêncio
como um segredo religioso se eu
respeitar esse juramento e não violar
seria digno de gozar de reputação dos
homens em todos os tempos e se transmite
o violar que acontece o contrário porque
que já naquela época se preocupado com
isso e ainda hoje fazem treinamento a
gente faz um juramento de coisas que a
gente transgride e que tem transmita
porque a relação médico paciente é
imprescindível para uma cura
então é hoje poucas coisas são regidas
com julgamento de honra
e esse caso de honra de participar de
uma posição que é regida por um
treinamento de um conhecimento médico na
grécia é um indivíduo é puro de produzir
ciência de tal maneira que o próprio
poder de armazenamento o que aconteceu
com isso o conhecimento médico se
proliferou de tal maneira que um
indivíduo não é mais capaz de absorver
todo esse conhecimento
então hoje um paciente tem uma última e
médicos que cuida de uma turma e essa
turma cada um cuidando um pedacinho
com isso a gente vai se especializando
muito em curar a doença e vai perdendo é
é a cura do paciente tem uma teoria
corrente de usar o exame pode falar pelo
paciente não pode não madeira está numa
aula na faculdade uma aula de grupos
pequenos com o professor e é e eu
brinquei com certeza senhoras paciente
tem tomografia relacionar se negocia
como copia ultra-som eu vou pôr a mão na
barriga dele como em caso de consciência
- compostura com um cão chamado uma
coisa fácil vamos ver na minha frente
ele olhou inchado está com medo do
paciente que é notável que estava
fumando dentro de um formato mais buraco
do cinto dele mostraram que ele tinha
emagrecido manchas na pele é é um idoso
você pode ver se ele está conseguindo
cuidar da sua própria roupa é onde gosto
não pode falar muita coisa na hora você
está vencendo não passei por um momento
de intimidade de repente ele pode ser
lembrada
a gente disse na consulta ele disse tudo
isso me convenceu
além disso como você está vendo paciente
você está expondo pra você ao área
vulnerável está deixando você mexer nele
nesse momento você tem a oportunidade de
falar num verbalmente pra ele 'você tem
cuidado com ele você tá mexendo no livro
você quer fazer o bem a lista com
permissão pra ele
deixa eu cuidar de você essa razão essa
mágica ela não é só unidade de ouvir mas
ela é replicado em ciência criança
sirlei neonatal que são pegadas no colo
são atualizadas melhor o mais rápido em
uma alta mais precocemente
cada vez mais aumenta o número de
doenças funcionais nosso meio dessas
funcionário da casa que já não sabe por
que aparece não tem alteração exame não
tem alterações a missão não tem rotina
de não ver nada só existam sintomas
isso acontece será que acontece porque a
nossa sociedade está um pouco doente
onde você quer levantar mais fácil bom
muito interessante você fala da relação
médico paciente
mas é uma relação médico-paciente eu sou
paciente e ser paciente a ser passivo
está falando pra mim você vai falar com
um médico porque afinal o ativo da
relação aos médicos está na hora da
gente parar de pensar que existe dois
lados e os médicos com os dois está na
hora da gente parar de pensar que a
gente é passível e é paciente passivo ea
gente tem que pegar em nossas mãos se a
ele como nosso processo de cura e não é
só em busca da saudável mas também em
desenvolver o seu processo de cura nas
decisões a cura pra se fazer isso
o primeiro ponto é mais importante
informação
nós já tentamos falar do doutor google
para a moda não tá na moda quando era
criança tinha uma prova desse tamanho na
casa medicina e saúde de um livro livro
da saúde
isso existia sempre existiu a diferença
é que naquela ocasião para você conhecer
alguém publicará uma coisa eo editor
você tinha que ter conteúdo para falar
hoje em dia
o google você tem uma infinidade de
informação muitas muito boas muito
importantes mas muita muito ruim e nós
precisamos saber filtrar a capacidade de
gerar informação é maior capacidade de
chutar
então tem algumas coisas que a gente tem
que pensar na hora de ver as informações
primeiro primeiro formação boa
geralmente assinada
eu tenho um blog no meu blog somente 1,3
por cento das pessoas dentro do meu
corpo mas ele pensou isso me dá uma
satisfação imensa porque as pessoas
entram lá ouvir o que têm a dizer e não
sabe que eu sou o que eu fiz que eu
estudei arrependimento por nada isso é
normal
o filme coloca fica igual a outras
pessoas que estão é e sem nenhum
interesse pessoais e ganhar dinheiro ou
de vender remédio outras coisas assim
então assinatura
a segunda coisa muito importante é não
acredite em coisas tão baixos
reguladoras
obviamente se não mudou agora os seus
problemas terminaram
geralmente essa besteira dificilmente um
laboratório um sentido vai ter uma
descoberta retumbante imediata sem que a
sociedade científica não tenha maturando
isso faz técnico as informações correm
ninguém faz nada sozinho então não tem
uma coisa que descobriu hoje e amanhã na
internet mas que ainda não conhece
bobagem tercera
se tiver uma coisa meio paranóico tipo a
a indústria não tem interesse que você
saiba disso é bobagem ninguém domina a
informação é dificilmente tem algum
outro o interesse escuso atrás dessas
coisas minha paranóia na questão e por
último a ação discute com seu médico
está lá para isso
a informação não é igual ao conhecimento
e informação e formação conhecimento
conhecimento pela informação participa
ativamente da sua cura mas se discuta
com essa média a segunda coisa muito
importante pra ser ativo na nação
processo de cura é perguntar exige
conhecer como você fala do seu médico se
você tem direito de saber para que
servem remédio tem o direito de saber o
risco da cirurgia e não adianta dizer a
um hospital público o cara não tem medo
de atender eu trabalho há 20 anos
só que não acho que isso vai mudar do
dia para a noite mas não tenho que a
cultura não mudar a cultura de se exigir
exigir não é chegar lá brigando com todo
mundo pronto socorro não é isso é
vagarosamente saber
exige-se com posicionar com o tempo nós
vamos e fazer com que os atendimentos
sejam diferentes
os médicos querem isso eles querem
aprender direito nunca tem de se tentar
alguma hora eles querem apenas brincar
uma vez eu estava na amazônia na
venezuela era mesmo a montanhosa área
humano e nós tínhamos um paciente lá que
tinha um câncer de pele e não havia
neurologista pra gente trouxe para são
paulo para ser tratada pelo instituto do
câncer de são paulo e depois de todos
esses anos eu tive a oportunidade de
acompanhar as lutas dele era um erro que
não falava português
o médico que obviamente não falava numã
tinha um tradutor pelo filho decidido
prova muito boa porque eles começaram
muito mal
ele estava obviamente resultado e eu
presenciei uma consulta pra mim daria
uma cena de um filme
o índio corpo médico assim que eu quero
dizer com isso é que naquele momento a
mágica aconteceu aquele indivíduo sem
falar a língua sem tema tendo uma
cultura completamente diferente do outro
entregou sua alma quer outro indivíduo
que tinha todo o interesse de cuidar
dele
essa mágica que é a arte de curar
então não precisa de mim tentar cortar
muita firula acontece neste momento nós
erramos eu tenho orgulho de pensar tem
médicos atendendo pronto poucos em
ambulatórios em consultórios questão é
anônimos fazendo o botão do anoa luta
chorando atendendo então nós médicos
podemos tentar encontrar mais humanidade
lamento mas com paixão e todos os
pacientes a procurar ser ativo no seu
processo de cura
isso vai fazer com que haja uma conexão
eo nosso melhor que você vai ser mais
bem tratado fora disso
obrigado